today we're going to look at some
selected questions from oppressi
today we're going to look at some
selected questions from a practice exam
for mathematics extension 2. not going
to have a look at every single question
because they're not all as interesting
or as challenging and for the students
of mine who attempted this practice exam
i'm going to focus on those questions
that either have something interesting
in the solution that is worth discussing
or the ones where we had some major
issues that are worth addressing in
terms of like common mistakes and
misconceptions okay so you'll see as we
go along through that i've highlighted
the questions i want us to have a look
at and the very first one is in multiple
choice and it's question one it says
what is the value of this definite
integral from not to 2 of the square
root of x on 4 minus x with respect to x
using this particular substitution and
they provide for you x equals 4 sine
squared theta so here are all of the
different options let's have a go and
see what emerges as we do our working
so i'm going to put this to one side and
let's write down first this is question
one
okay now we'll begin just to write down
the particular
substitution that they've given it's x
equals 4 sine squared theta so we see
these trigonometric substitutions all of
the time
as you know when we have a think about a
definite integral there's really three
things that need to be changed number
one we have to change the boundaries
that we are going to be evaluating this
integral within you've got a fiddle with
the integrand the things being
integrated so we will substitute
wherever we saw x for instance we will
see we'll replace it with a 4 sine
square theta
and then we also need to change the
variable of integration so we're going
to need to know what dx on d theta is
and that will change you know we used to
be integrating with respect to x then
we'll be integrating with respect to
theta so what i'll do is just on the
right hand side here i'll pull all of
that sort of ancillary working that will
help me do the substitution so to begin
with i'm actually going to think as i go
from
left to right through my integral i'm
going to start with the boundaries okay
so i'm going to go with x equals 0 that
was the original boundary what am i
going to get for theta well that's going
to give me well 4 sine squared theta is
equal to 0. now you can see if i divide
through by 4 you get sine squared theta
on the left hand side and still 0 on the
right hand side and i want sine squared
is equal to 0 or therefore sine theta is
going to be equal to 0 and there's an
obvious solution for sine theta equals 0
it's going to be theta equals 0 okay
come back to that thought in a second
let's have a look at the other boundary
that's x equals 2 and this makes a
little clearer one of the primary issues
that we want to drill down into and
that's why i'm doing this question as a
demonstration with using trigonometric
substitutions for any kind of integral
let's write out what we're going to get
here you got the 4 sine squared theta is
equal to 2 because that's just the
substitution for x
divide through by 4 like i did
previously and now i take the square
root of both sides now unlike before we
had sine theta is equal to zero so
neither positive nor negative here i've
got a half and when you take the square
root i do have to deal with the positive
and negative we actually get plus or
minus one on the square root of two
now when you've got this plus minus
right um when you were first introduced
to solving trigonometric equations um
things like you know sine theta is equal
to uh you know root three on two for
instance okay one of the things you
would say is oh which quadrants am i in
or which you know am i looking at an
acute angle obtuse reflex etc okay now
the nice thing about this plus or minus
is you kind of don't have to worry about
which quadrant you're in because you're
in all of them right if sine theta can
be plus or minus one on root two then
you can have the base angle um in the in
the first quadrant you can have that
same base angle in the second quadrant
so the obtuse version and then you've
got the two reflex angles that go along
with that now that makes it easier to
solve because you don't have to think
about like command quadrants one and
three or two and four that kind of thing
but it makes it harder because in this
case i actually want a single boundary
value for theta right now i could write
out fairly easily maybe you can think of
the base angle for one on root two it's
just going to be pi on 4 but it raises
the question just like it did earlier on
because theta equals 0 is not the only
solution to this equation up here it
raises the big question about well why
did i choose these boundaries if pi on 4
is a solution to this equation right
here then so is 3 pi on 4 and so is 5 pi
over 4 and so is 7 pi on 4 and all of
those repeated
on and on and on for the rest of the
sine function
we will come back to that question a
little bit later on when we come up with
a solution but i just want to flag that
or sort of
put that post in the ground and have you
thinking about why it is that i chose
this particular value for theta for zero
and for pi on four okay
so deal with my boundaries um i'm going
to deal with my integrand when i just
substitute all the x's for four sine
squared thetas okay uh and then the
other thing the third thing is the
variable of integration right so as i
mentioned before i need to know what
oopsies easy
dx on d theta is
so just a straight differentiation here
so you can see here i've got the 4
hanging out the front and then there's
just a
reasonably straightforward use of chain
rule on this right it's sine theta
squared so that
4 comes out the front right uh just the
constant coefficient i multiply by the
power squared um and then i will reduce
the power by one which gives me sine
theta to the power of one and then that
was the outside now i've got to do the
inside so inside derivative the inside
function is sine so the inside
derivative is cos so that gives me this
and i could write that as 8 but i think
it's simple enough i'll do that when i'm
doing my substitution
okay so therefore i've got all my pieces
ready now i'm going to write my integral
from x equals 0 to x equals 2 of the
square root of we've got x on 4 minus x
close my square root with respect to x
what's that going to be equal to well
let's change them one piece at a time
we've got new boundaries in theta so
instead of going not to 2 i've decided
to go from naught to pi on 4. then i've
got the big square root here and now i'm
going to shove in all my 4 sine squared
thetas wherever i saw x's which is in
two spots so i'm going to get this first
up on the numerator there
and then on the denominator and you
might be now seeing why
they've given you they've supplied this
particular
substitution you're getting 4 minus 4
sine squared theta which you can see is
leaning towards the use of the
pythagorean identity worth pointing that
out because you know had this question
not been a multiple choice question i
mean it's a fair bit of work even for
multiple choice but had it not been
multiple choice like worth three marks
for instance
i think it would have been totally fair
game as you might know in extension two
we expect you to be able to do uh
integration by substitution where the
substitution is not provided right in
extension one we always tell you what to
do but in section two we're like you
know what sometimes you work it out and
i think this is one of those cases where
you look down here at this denominator
and you think ah can i do something that
would give me nice cancelling happening
here with the pythagorean identity and
that is indeed what's going to unfold
shortly getting ahead of myself let's uh
close that square root there
and to replace that
dx there i'm going to have the uh the 8
sine theta cos theta here d theta that i
worked out when i differentiated okay so
that let's just write that on the end
multiplied by
eight sine theta cos theta
d theta all right happy times all the
substitution has been none now we just
need to tidy up this thing and see what
emerges and evaluate because it is of
course a definite integral let's have a
look here
before i can start to actually work out
what the primitive is there clearly is a
lot of simplifying work to do here in
the integrand so when you have a look
you're going to get
this is 4 sine squared theta and then on
the bottom here this is going to be 4
cos squared theta do you see that right
so therefore
the 4s are going to cancel and this sine
squared over cos squared when you take
the square root both of them have been
squared so therefore i'm just going to
get sine theta on cos theta
i could have just as easily have written
that as tan but looking at the rest of
the
integrand i see that there's kind of no
point because i'm about to do some
convenient cancelling for myself right
you can see here i've got the i'm just
going to grab it like so
i've got this 8 sine theta cos theta
hanging out on the end here and so you
can clearly see my cos thetas are going
to cancel and so while i'm at it i'm
going to
you know
bring that 8 out the front where it's
easier to see so i'll put that 8 right
there i've now got a sine squared theta
because you can see this sign and this
sign combining
and then i that's all with respect to
theta so this is looking really good
because as an extension one student i've
got double angle identities that can
help me here right i don't have to do
this as a reverse chain rule i can say
oh i know that this is going to be equal
to oopsie daisy
2 sine squared theta is 1 minus cos 2
theta if you don't know your double
angle identities well enough by this
point that is probably an indicator to
you about practice like i wouldn't say
go and memorize these and put a lot of
effort into that
i know them because i've used them a lot
so that's that's what i would suggest to
you
so from naught to plan 4
if you take out a factor of 4 you get
left with that 2 sine squared theta so
that leaves me with 4 outside of 1 minus
cos 2 theta
d theta and i think at this point i am
actually ready to integrate
so um big square brackets um i might as
well pop that four out the front it's
not useful to me inside the integrand
anymore um the one is going to integrate
up into theta remember that's the
variable integration and then i'm going
to get let's see here so
um
minus cos is going to come from minus
sign and also i'm going to divide
through i'm thinking about reverse chain
rule here because of the the 2 theta on
the inside there
and that goes from naught to pi on four
okay looking good let's go ahead and
evaluate do my upper bound first so
four's out to the front
you're putting your pi and four
that looks like it's going to cancel
nicely you're going to get minus a half
of sine
2
times pi on 4 which of course is pi on 2
and that's going to simplify out because
sine of pine 2 is of course 1. and then
having done the upper boundary my lower
boundary 0 here 0 there sine 0 is 0 as
well so that's really convenient i'm
going to be subtracting a big fat 0.
okay
from there what have i got well 4 times
pi on 4 that just gives me pi and then
in here what do we say this is going to
be equal to 1. so if i say this is equal
to 1 therefore i'm really just getting 4
times negative a half which last i
checked was minus 2 and if you have a
look back let's just bring up that exam
again there it is
that's looking like option b for me so
i'm just going to
write that like so ta-da got my solution
okay
now just putting that back to one side
let's return to this issue here that i
flagged about these particular
boundaries and why i chose these ones
and not other ones right
why did i know or how could i tell that
say you know
negative pi on four like i actually went
round
in a positive direction but uh it's
pretty easy to see you know if i put in
sine theta equals negative 1 or root 2
and if you just say for example blindly
reach your calculator and say well
what's um sine inverse of negative 1 or
root 2 it's going to give you negative
pi on 4 and you might think well is that
a valid answer you know why or why not
now it's pretty let's put this in a
different color it's pretty clear to see
what will happen if we for example
consider what happens if we try
using
theta equals negative pi on 4. so this
is going to be an illustration of how i
can tell that this is not going to be a
plausible answer and why i can somewhat
dismiss it out of hand right
if i try this out
everything that i did from here through
my substitution through here all of it's
going to be the same except this
boundary is just going to sit there as
negative pi on 4 all the way through for
some amount of time so therefore it
really kind of kicks in at this line
here when i do the evaluation that's
when things are going to be really
different so let's see what happens if i
actually put in negative pi on 4 instead
of pi on 4 right
i'm going to have 4
of theta minus a half sine 2 theta and
i'm going to go from 0 to negative pi on
4. noting that this is going to be
backwards because negative pi and 4 is
to the left of 0 but like you can't
change it like you can't just say oh i'd
like to make it backwards because
if you wanted to switch that order
around you'd have to switch these two
around like you'd have to multiply
through by a factor of negative 1 to
indicate you were going along the
interval backwards right so i'm going to
stick with this and when you do the
straight substitution this should look
familiar right you'll go 4 and then out
the front you'll have a negative pi 4
and then minus a half of sine of
negative pi on two you'll still get zero
on the end there because let's just
change that to a square of a square
bracket because we have not changed the
lower boundary it's still zero and
that's where i got the zero from in the
first place okay
now what you can see here hopefully is
that number one we've flipped around the
sine of the pi on four it's negative pi
four and because sine in here is s i n s
i and e really because this is an odd
function flipping around the sine of the
angle that you're supplying into it will
flip around the sign of the whole
function as well so therefore you're
going to get negative pi
plus
2. so you have the exact opposite answer
that you got from here now you might say
yeah well how did you know that that
isn't valid right and the key that i
would suggest is remembering that pi is
about 3.14 so this is minus 3.14 let's
just write that as approximate
approximately equal to minus 3.14 plus
2. so this is about negative 1.14
and i can immediately know without
appealing to anything
sort of really advanced or sophisticated
this can't be a plausible answer because
this is negative now how do i know the
answer can't be negative look back to
the original question here it is right
here
if you investigate this integral right
have a think about this for a moment
what is it that indicates to you when
you have a look at this that a negative
antar is completely unreasonable and
where my brain goes is well this is a
square root function right
i am dealing with thankfully this is not
complex analysis this is calculus with
real variables so therefore what's
underneath this square root
is going to be real numbers you're going
to get a positive number out of this and
therefore if you're only going to get
positive numbers out of this your entire
function has to stay above the x-axis so
therefore whatever integral you take its
signed area
will be positive remember areas that we
work out from integration can be
positive or negative depending on where
they are in relation to your horizontal
axis all of this is going to be above
and so forth therefore this
area that
will be equivalent to this definite
integral has to be positive
and so that's why minus negative pi plus
2 that's clearly wrong right this is no
good no dice okay
and just to illustrate this right what's
actually going on here here is what the
square root of x on 4 minus x looks like
and the particular area that i'm asking
for is this sort of black shaded thing
in here
so this is how i can know right even
when you have a look at this point here
you're like hey hold on a second this is
going to be negative right so therefore
that's one of the reasons why you can
think this
and i can understand why you might be a
little dissatisfied with this argument
at least i was when i first came up with
it because you make this decision about
which boundaries to choose long before
you really have a clear sense of what
that integrand is going to look like and
therefore what function you're going to
be evaluating so you'd be forgiven for
thinking yeah but how did you know that
early on right
especially when you think about well
once you do simplify what that integrand
looks like 4 times 1 minus cos 2 theta
four times one minus cos two theta is
going to be a function that when you
integrate it because it's been raised up
by one unit normally you would think
that cos sits between negative one and
one its range right when you add one to
that you shift it up to go from zero to
two that coefficient four out the front
means it's not from zero to two it'll be
from zero to eight okay but the issue is
going to be the same that you're gonna
get positives everywhere so how did i
know right now the the plain fact of it
is that there isn't um there isn't just
a single pair of values one for x equals
zero and one for x equals two that will
give you the right answer and that's
really clear to see
by thinking about this what created this
problem in the first place right
the trigonometric function that we
replace our original square root x minus
4 and x 4 minus x function with this
function is periodic so therefore you
can see over here on the left hand side
shaded in blue this is my naught to pi
on 4 of this function that i created so
this blue area is equal to this black
area sorry for my scale being a little
bit off but the reason why is because i
wanted to show you over here if you add
2 pi to both of the boundaries i chose
not and pi and 4 if you go 2 pi and 9 pi
on 4 clearly they will give you that
same area the blue and the green
areas they are identical right
but it doesn't make sense to go and try
and evaluate this because it's like oh
gross like why would you do that you're
going to get an equivalent value over
here so just choose the ones that are
convenient to you okay
i guess what i'm trying to say is when
you have a look back at a question like
this there are some clues like you know
the fact that it's all going to be
positive that will skew you in the
direction of saying oh i should just
choose values that will give me
positives right
but otherwise you do have to reckon with
the fact it's kind of a [ __ ] in the
armor of using trigonometric
substitution that in fact there is an
unambiguously one pair of boundaries
that are the boundaries that make sense
there's just ones that are more
convenient or less convenient and
several of them will give us the right
answer but you have to be genuinely
careful because others will give you the
wrong one right
it turns out by the way that part of the
reason why this is wrong is not because
negative part 4 is just impossible
but because you would have to choose a
different appropriate boundary for the x
equals zero solution in order to go
from left to right rather than from
right to left that's that was the issue
here right you went from zero to
negative pi on four so you're
integrating backwards and that's what
gave you this um this negative result
right
so all that to say
you know trigonometric substitutions are
a tool they're not magical they don't
always give you the right answer in the
real world you're going to just have all
these tools in your toolbox and you just
have to make choices about why you
choose one over the other
and
under what circumstances you know the
tool is appropriate and you've got to be
careful how you use them okay